when it comes to treating diseases like
cancer modern medicine has an impressive
arsenal and one of its most versatile
weapons are y-shaped proteins called
monoclonal antibodies our immune systems
already produce their own antibodies
they come in billions of variations each
matching a specific target such as a
particular toxin bacteria or virus when
they bind to their target they send a
signal this bacterium is now marked for
destruction these naturally produced
antibodies are pretty effective but in
the 1970s scientists figured out how to
mass-produce them they can take any
specifically targeted antibody and make
huge numbers of identical clones which
means you can produce monoclonal
antibodies for almost any disease you
can think of which brings us on to
cancer mutated cells that start growing
out of control can be deadly but the
body's immune system isn't defenseless
meats of CTL it's a type of white blood
cell that can detect infected or mutated
cells and when it finds one it secretes
toxic molecules that initiate a
self-destruct sequence
but the CTL do sometimes need to be
reined in if they get over-enthusiastic
the immune system can start causing
collateral damage
attacking healthy cells
fortunately the CTLs can be turned off
by activating a molecule called PD 1 the
trouble with having an off switch is
that cancer cells can exploit it many
cancer cells protect themselves for the
counter receptor called PDL 1 this is
where monoclonal antibodies come in
scientists can use one of two types one
that finds the PD 1 molecule or another
that goes for PDL 1 thanks to the
monoclonal antibodies all of the CTLs
are fully activated and can blast away
the cancer this is just one way that
when a clonal antibodies can be used
they've already proven effective against
a whole range of cancers and yet more
are still being developed with their
ability to be targeted at specific
diseases monoclonal antibodies are
turning out to be a game-changer and one
of our most effective weapons in the
fight against cancer
[Music]